it was a bad case she was framed my dad  did a lot of rough things in his life so  did I I went to jail for a crime that I  was guilty of that particular crime that  he did 38 years in prison for he was  innocent off and I'll take that to my  grave real awe percent I investigated  that case spoke to every witness they  recanted that testimony  we gave him a lie detector test prove  they lied at the trial the FBI was  complicit and turning them against my  dad it was a bad case she was framed  thousand percent people say well you  know he got away with so much that's not  how our system supposed to work they  have enough tools and weapons the  government to get people the right way  they're not supposed to do that no  matter what or who you are because if  they do it against the bad guys one day  they can do it against the good guys if  it suits them so why we say tell people  look you wouldn't want my dad's life